C'est l'heure d'un nouveau Let's Play, les amis,  sur Outlast 2 ! Putain..
Ça fait 3 ans que j'attends le 2
Je le rappelle : il y aura un épisode qui sera mit en ligne tous les deux jours
C'est un bonus ce let's play par rapport aux videos que je fais chaque semaines
Il y aura toujours quatres vidéos normales sur autre chose qu'Outlast 2 chaque semaines
Alors j'avais juste joué à la démo sur PS4 sinon je n'ai regardé aucun trailer
aucune bande d'annonce pour ne pas être spoilé pour avoir un maximum de...
Plaisir
Ambiance obscurité posée et pas tamisée posée, c'est parti.
(Squeezie lit le texte de son écran)
Puta*n, la pression mec est elle, elle est... comme ça
*rires* C'est génial puta*n, c'est trop bien comme angle
Le vieux reportage là puta*n
MERCI DE LIRE LE TEXTE A L'ECRAN
Ohh !
OK je cadre ! Comme un professionnel
"Rires"
Ouais, tu fais des fake news
*Cri d'extase* J'suis tellement !!
J'suis tellement content,
puta*n !!!!
Depuis le temps qu'on attendait ça !
*Surpris* Ohhh, ça commence direct?
Holy shit!
Ohhhh mais, c'est le bâtiment
heu... dans lequel on était dans l'intro heu... dans la démo pardon,
du jeu sur PS4,
ça fait longtemps que j'ai pas joué à des jeux d'horreur en plus !!
J'suis complètement paniqué !!! Quel est-ce casier?
To Jessica
First Place
D'accord ...
Ok... très bien...  Mhhhh
Rohhhh mec, je sens j'vais p-
Ok....c'est un souvenir c'est ça (bégaie)
Donc ça, c'est dans le passé à mon avis, c'est une sorte de cauchemar !
C'est un cauchemar qu'il est en train de faire heu...
après avoir touché le sol suite au crash d'hélico à mon avis, un truc du genre!!
Rahhhh puta*n il marche plus vite que nous....
Beaucoup trop de pression...
Oh puta*n!!! Et vous qui vouliez un peu d'jeux d'horreur parce que ça vous manquez.....
J'pense qu'on va avoir notre dose mon gars pour 8 années,
très clairement !
Oh puta*n.... le sound design du jeu il est...
*Choqué*
Okkkkkkkk
Merciii, je l'avais dis que c'était un cauchemar, c'était sûr !
Il est.... j'ai cru qu'il était attaché mais c'est sa montre ! *rires*
J'panique pour rien !
Oh Ohh  lève-toi grand gars ça va aller....
J'espère qu'il est pas blessé ...
*Crie de force*
Okkkk, on a la caméra,
avec un maximum de batterie, je l'espère !
Puta*n, faut que je descends, faut que j'aille chercher ma go ?
Ouais.....
Ok, objectif trouver Lynn,
d'accord, ça marche en appuyant sur TAB pour l'objectif...
Wouohhh ahhhh, j'peux pas sauter plus que ça ?
Ah bas c'est bon, c'est pas grave... puta*n j'me dis ça va être compliqué mec !
Roh lalalalala mais mec,
on sent tellement les années de travail, c'est incroyable!!!
Ok, super !
J'peux descendre plus bas encore oùù ouais, par là...
oula, ça va être le grand saut là
Attends, pour accéder à une corniche, déplacez-vous dans sa direction, ok....
ça va nous être utile tout ça parce que mec, quand on va fuir les mecs psychopathes qui vont vouloir
nous tuer à maintes reprises, on sera bien content de savoir faire ça!!!
Heu.... gauche contrôle, ok....
Faut , faut que je m'en souvienne, avec la panique et le stress que je vais avoir quand je me ferais pours...
poursuivre chez pas si..... si je me souviendrais mec!!!!
Les événements importants doivent être enregistrés,
appuyez sur clic droit pour lever votre caméscope. L'enregistrement se fera automatiquement, d'accord....
Cela que pointez correctement le caméscope sur l'événement à enregistrer.
Pointez le caméscope sur l'événement jusqu'à ce que le cercle rouge soit rempli
pour l'enregistrer
complètement.
D'accord.....
Nouvelle mécanique, alors ?!
Puta*n c'est rigolo et à la fin,
il va avoir un montage de tous c'est moment qu'on aura fait?
Vidéo enregistrée. Regardez les vidéos enregistrées pour en savoir plus sur les événements et les objectifs, ok.....
Heu..... donc, je peux la rejouer !
C'est génial....
Il commente quoi, puta*n c'est génial, mec c'est génial, ça me plaît déjà !
Bon alors, il y a qui?
Il y a le pilote, c'est ça?
Heu.... elle est pas là.... puta*n mec si elle
s'est fait enlevé par les.... puta*n de mec là, qu'on
a vu dans la démo. Vision nocturne,
hop et F,
ohhhhhh, même ça j'suis content les gars de retrouver puta*n, c'est super !
C'est génial ! Bon par contre, heu.... on vas faire la technique
heu..... économie de piles mec.....
Roaa, ça commence comme ça?
Mec, je sais que t'y crois pas mais t'es en état de choc mais...
Oh puta*n ça c'est... c'est une touche horri- ...  Ohla,
qu'es ce qui ce passe, ok.. c'est une touche horrible parce que
ça veut dire qu'à des moments, on se fera poursuivre faudra regarder derrière comme des....
des c*ns!!
Ahh, j'aime pas du tout cette touche mec, ça met la pression
bon, on continue hein, on s'enfonce!!!
Ho lalalala, c'est beau, c'est beau
, c'est fluide, mais que demander, quoi!!!
Ahh, on va revivre la démo en fait la en vrai!!
On va revivre la démo!!
Waouhhh, dans la maison, est-ce que c'est un bon plan?
Puta*n, c'est là où il est...
dommage...
Ahhhh puta*n mec, c'est la démo ça!!!
J'ai cru entendre des bruits de pas.. non, c'est les miens, puta*n ça y est là j'ai ... la
parano qui commence déjà quoi...
Il y a quelqu'un là, allô?
J'peux ouvrir? Vas-y j'ouvre, j'vais voir, il y a quelqu'un ou pas là?
Oh mec, j'me casse direct, j'me casse direct,
quelle idée de merde, faut que je retrouve ma go et que.. je m'en aille!!!
Faut vite que je la retrouve, faut que jette un coup d'œil, appuyez
longuement sur A ah non, me dit pas que....
puta*n.....
ça recommence!!!
J'suis content mais pas trop!!
Allez, on y va, c'est parti, c'est parti !
Oh puta*n, ouais ah oui on peut aller se cacher dans les bidons, c'est ça? Bon aller on vas rush, hein?
Ahhhh ohhhh puta*n.....
J'suis sous pression mec mais level mille!!!
J'peux frapper? Il y'a quelqu'un?
Ok, je rentre...., il y a une note!!!
Waouh, il y a des cris,
puta*n de m*rde, on est pas bien les amis....
Heu.... cher père, notre dieu bien aimé à continuer à me bénir de ses visions et je suis
plus certaine que jamais que l'ennemie approche avec chaque jour qui passe
je nettoyais les taches de plancher de la chambre de Daniel, lorsqu'une musique bénit m'a traversée pour me plonger au cœur d'une vision.
Très bien, bon ce qui est bien c'est qu'ils sont pas fous, ce qui est bien c'est qu'ils sont vraiment pas fous,
heu......, ça fait plaisir!!!
Il est où l'autre b*tard, mec?
Je sais que y'a un mec qui rode pas loin, c'est
évident, c'est d'une évidence considérable
et il va à un moment donné ce mettre à nous courir après!!
Il y a un portail, je suis obligée de passé par la maison bien évidemment !!
Pour ouvrir les fenêtres, appuyer sur, ahhh ok....
ça va aller, ça va aller, ça va aller puta*n, je l'avais oublié celui-là!!
Oh shit, oh shit...
Certaines portes ont des verrous qui peuvent être utilisés pour les verrouiller ou les déverrouiller.
Nouvelle mécanique aussi du coup j'crois
pas qu'il y est ça dans enfin je...ça me dis rien...ok!!
Bon bas mec de toutes façons heu...
on vas y aller par ce petit trou... Ctrl ok....
Rohlala, le game-play
est film mes mais c'est un truc de ouf, tous s'enchaîne bien parfaitement bien,
un peu à la Mirror's Edge quoi c'est très très fort
Mec je cours...y a des bruits, j'vous jure qu'il y a des bruits autour de moi
Je vous jure qu'y a des bruits autour de moi c'est horrible...HORRIBLE
Complainte de sage-femme, l'enfant arrive, prépare ton couteau, l'enfant arrive
Sage-femme de nuit, mère souillée de l'intérieur par l'ennemi
Mère souillée de l'intérieur par l'ennemi, création de Dieu sauvée par le pêché
Très bien bon on voit l'ambiance hein, on voit l'ambiance clairement de...de...
...de Outlast 2
et elle nous fait ... à la fois plaisir et pas du tout plaisir
Puta*n ... pas du tout plaisir là en l'occurence, mec
Holy shit
Aller on y va, on y va, c'est partit
Ah faut que je m'accroupisse, autant pour moi
Je suis tellement paniqué que je ... je n'arrive plus à réfléchir correctement
Ah nann, nann, on est en train de s'enfoncer
mais mec c'est le pire truc à faire
Ramper, oooh, puta*n ça il va falloir le voir
On peut passer sous des portiques comme ça
c'est pas évident
What ? Le livre de vie de l'agneau immolé ? Qu'est ce qui se passe là ?
Moi je connaissais le livre de vie du poulet braisé
mais heuuu ... agneau imm- ...
Ohlala, mais on l'entend parler quoi
genre, il est vachement proche en fait ... il est collé
Oh oui, une pile
Ok, je me souviens ... puta*n mais mec !
Mais elle est juste à côté en vrai, attend je vois rien
Ok y'a des bûches qui me retiennent, c'est bon
Elle est où ? Où est la personne qui parlait, mec ?
Oh ça me pète les cou*lles, y'a un feu qui ...
*cri*
quoi ? quoi ? quoi ?
quoi déjà, déjà, mais nan, mais nan
Mais ce n'est pas possible
Mais, mais où, mais où sommes nous là, mais où sommes nous
Je sais pas où elle est hein mec elle a disparu,c'était une vision
C'était une vision,c'était une vision
Oh mec,vas-y on va aller chez toi
Y'a peut-être ma gow.Ma gow où es-tu ?!
Nickel ! J'espère que c'est pas ton sang
Du bandage !
Voir combien de bandages, appuyez sur Tab
Ok, ouais j'ai compris,t'inquiètes pas j'ai compris l'objectif
Euh vas-y hein j'ouvre. Lynn !
Lynn!
Putain faut que je la trouve on pourra manger du Lindt ensemble
Le chocolat Lindt ! oh puta*n la blague qui rassure qui nous met bien pendant ce let's play incroyable!
Et probablement le dernier vu l'ambiance qui règne
*cri*
DEPECHE-TOI ELLE VA TE TIRER PAR LES PIEDS
Puta*n ! Ca m'énerve ce genre de situation
Ca m'énerve ce genre de situation ! Quand tu sais que t'as une partie de ton corps qui dépasse de l'autre côté là ou il y a le méchant
Tu sais que t'es impuissant
D'accord j'ai compris le délire
Je vois pas trop à quoi ça va nous servir ici mais ok
Ok,c'est très bien fait puta*n
Oh en fait c'est pas du tout comme dans la démo ! La démo c'était vraiment un truc fait sur mesure
*soupirs* Ils sont barés mec
Très clairement, on est dans le village des gens fous
Voilà on va pas se mytho
J'espère là, je connais Outlast
Je sais très bien que le sol va se casser et qu'on va tomber
nez à nez avec quelqu'un qu'on avait vraiment pas envie de voir
Ca va être....
Mec,c'était sûr là
C'était sûr!
C'était évident mec. Et là on va se faire tirer par les pieds
On va se retourner y'aura un mec
Mais arrête
Et il prend le temps de répondre quand même
Mais c'est pas avec ce style déjà que tu vas convertir quiconque, vraiment
Bon bref,allez on dégage
Ca me fait très très peur. Et je peux me barrer? Ouais mais elle est autour quoi
Puta*n mec, ça sent pas bon
Ca sent pas bon
Nan,c'est là d'où je viens ou c'est là où il faut que j'aille?
Oh c'est fort ça !
Donc y'a un mec
Hop on verrouille la porte comme ça mec comme ça on est tranquille !
On va essayer de guetter par là
J'arrête pas de m'allonger mec
On sait qu'il y a du monde là, attends voir là où ils sont
Ok ils sont vers la droite, y'a personne à gauche ok, alors
C'est parti !
Il est là-bas
De toute façon mec, il va forcément me repérer
Attends on va tenter d'y aller en mode accroupi dans les hautes herbes
Peut-être que ça passera,mec il va nous repérer c'est sûr
Ah nan c'est bon, regardez
On est bien là
On est ultra bien mec
Là y'a plus de plantes !
Je peux passer en dessous?
Y'a un autre mec!
Oh y'en a deux !
Pourquoi?
Y'en a un à gauche et un à droite
Ouais les renards c'est nous en l'occurrence c'est ça et toi tu veux tuer du renard
Puta*n de fous de merde
Il faut qu'on courre mec, on n'a pas le choix, il faut se lever
prendre ses boules et courir tel un athlète
Puta*n !
Faut y aller hein, ok je pense c'est maintenant qu'il faut y aller
Ok ! On est caché
On est caché, on est dans les hautes herbes
Faut aller tout droit à mon avis, le problème c'est que le mec rode juste derrière nous
Et ça ça donne un maximum de pression
Comme tes pneus chez le garagiste !
pardon
Il faut que j'évacue la pression d'une manière ou d'une autre
C'est quoi ça ?!
Oh yes !
Oh je sais pas ce que c'était mec mais ça m'a sauvé la vie
C'est vrai ça
Comme si, c'est bizzare mec
Oh shit ! J'fais quoi quand j'suis là ?
Faut que j'ouvre ça ?
D'accord
D'accord, d'accord
C'est par là, d'accord
D'accord
Mais en fait c'est un village, ouais, ils sont endoctrinés dans une secte en fait
C'est une secte en gros, voilà, on est dans une puta*n de secte
Et c'est hyper flippant
Cette femme ! NAN IL PARLE DE MA FEMME
Faut que j'aille la sauver
Oh puta*n la porte la plus longue du monde à déverrouiller
Oh nan elle va mourir, oh elle a un bâillon !
Nan
Je m'en fou de ça
Elle est où?
Comment je la sauve?
Comment je la sauve ?!
Faut que je déplace ça, je peux pas
Je peux pas,nan mais ça c'est des cellules je suis pas au bon endroit du tout là
Par là?
Caméra. Y'a rien, une clef ! Ok j'ai trouvé la clef !
C'est bon ! Clef de la prison ! Faut que j'ouvre une cellule?
Par là regardez, ok
Fils de p*te
Oh espèce de gros fils de p*te
Allez clef de la prison
J'espère que y'a pas un deuxième mec comme ça là dedans, nan c'est bon
Ok j'ai un bandage, ça va se fight, faut que je la sauve! Vite ok on va monter c'est bon
Elle est où... ? Elle est où... ?
"Bloqué". Mais non, mais non, mais non...
"Vous pouvez vous cacher dans les armoires".
Ça c'est très mauvais signe
Il va y avoir un mec...